[Music]
oh maybe he's still sleeping
dad some of clark's larger fragments are
now expected to enter our atmosphere
that's right and now those are just what
are they saying
more the same
where are they going i don't know
when the first chunks is about to hit
only part of it it's going in the ocean
but you look at that
where's explosion
we now are getting word that the
fragment has skipped
central florida wait are some more
pieces gonna hit
come on let's go put the sky's on fire
two days they got it all wrong there's a
ton of fragments planet killers
space agencies are predicting an
extinction-level event
we're going to be together all right get
them we're just trying to get to safety
they've been tracking the military
flights to bunkers and greenlight
it's our only chance
[Music]
clark's largest fragment will hit in
less than 24 hours
i swear i'm gonna get my family in
that bunker i know if you are hearing
this broadcast
seek shelter immediately what is it
what's going on
shelter immediately safe shelter
immediately
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dreamed them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one he'll lose
that one too
[Applause]
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg to escape
what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
hello duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
[Music]
oh
and initiate sequences
i'm sorry to be the one to tell you this
but you got yourself killed
at rst we'd rebuild the most important
assets in the us military
soldiers like yourself you're the first
who we've successfully managed to bring
back
but improved enhanced with the
technology in your veins
you have an army inside you that will
not only make you stronger he will heal
you instantly
now tell me do you remember anything
where are you going i gotta finish
business
and kill
oh that's not good
all right sun down
and initiate sequence
[Music]
okay who is the next target for
elimination
tell me do you remember anything do i
know you guys i don't think so
i've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes ain't
an initiate sequence
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
[Music]
that is absolutely fantastic
[Music]
i feel like i just heard this are they
playing with some repeat
am i dead you're in a coma
everyone in a coma goes to the same
common space
here in coma some people develop unique
abilities
in order to discover those abilities the
person needs a little push
to be put in danger i'm wondering what
your special ability is going to be
the man from the balcony was he the
leader
he taught us how to survive we're here
for a reason
everyone who's here didn't make it in
reality
they didn't have a future there
you haven't figured out anything yet
have you
i'm the commander here
this world is made of memories
how did they get here get down there's
an island
free of reapers somewhere in the coma
we're always looking for people who can
help us get there
is this my life now i remember that i
couldn't be together with who i wanted
to be
here it's possible
our world would never appreciate
something unusual even if it's a hundred
times better
what do you need reality for after that
we need to wake
up you can't wake up
do you understand your body is there in
coma you are here
there's nothing you can do about it life
in coma is as real as it gets
i said hold it
all i have for you is a word
[Music]
tenant it'll open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
use it carefully
[Music]
to do what i do i need some idea of the
threat we face
as i understand it we're trying to
prevent world war iii
i'm not saying i'm gonna get in here no
something worse
i got do you have an interest in a
certain
russian national
might just bring me in you really want
to know
you can communicate with the future
time travel no inversion
aim it and pull the trigger
you're shooting the bullet you're
catching it
well i've seen too much well we'll try
and keep up
your duty transcends national interests
this is about survival seems
bold hold i'm fine with that we're going
to say nuts
this is where our wheels collect
how would you like to die old
you chose the wrong profession
[Music]
well that's hasn't happened yet
there are people in the future who need
us
we need a tenant we need to save them
here and now
it's reversing the flow of time
wasn't us being here now and it never
[Music]
happened
you want to crash a plane we're not from
the air no it's so dramatic
well how big a plane
that part is a little dramatic
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no
fault lines no fracking no loud music
even
is shaking on a daily basis
under the dining table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it faith
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband fee renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
it's called science taskmaster he
controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
than us
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found it best
not to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay duck and go my plan was to drive us
away
glorious plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
and me my choice
i'm done running
[Music]
uh
here's what's going to happen natasha
don't slouch i'm not slouching
you're going to get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god
all right enough all of you i didn't say
anything that's not fair
look at this all those years in the big
city we finally got out
we're living the dream maybe
it is a dream
then everything just blew up
big flash like a pink light or actually
i don't even know what color it was it
wasn't like any color i'd ever seen
before
looks like a meteorite
i think it's radioactive i mean it's
from space right i mean your rights are
generally no more dangerous than
ordinary rocks
[ __ ] something that big just
disappear did you plant those
no wart come here for a sec
oh god what are you doing
it's talking to me who's talking to you
[Music]
it's in the static it's in the moisture
it's in here is out there
what's out there is in here now
everything's under control
oh i hear you so in denial that thing
from the meteorite
changes everything around it
[Music]
can you believe me now i don't know what
i believe anymore
everything's gonna be a-okay
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you the gift you always have
if there's an answer to your disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i don't want to see you get hurt more
than you already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
i went from time i feel like more alive
than ever
increased strength and speed
[Music]
the ability to use echolocation
even overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing
what's up doc
[Music]
yulia can you tell me why you decided to
help the alien
at what point did you start having
feelings for him
do i have to answer they're back again
you you're in danger
you all went too far in your research we
have to get out of here
you can come back
but she must be eliminated so this is a
cyber attack but not from this planet
you know i don't belong here dad
everything's gonna be fine
i don't even have a passport how are we
gonna cross the border we'll have to
cook up a corruption scam
no more cell phones no more digital
[Music]
technology
help me
[Music]
many homes have the pretence of being
ideal
but these homes really are ideal
it's not exactly what we're looking for
[Music]
wait no no i don't think this is the
right way yeah this is the way we came
in
no is it did we just do some kind of
loop
hello
i've never heard such silence
what if they don't come
what are we supposed to do
this house is forever a perfect
environment for a young family
people like to be alone sometimes not be
with each other
all the time
just gotta have a bottom this is
something i could do please just let me
do this
i want to go home
that's nature that's just the way things
are
[Music]
there she is guess what
daddy is gonna get you dressed for
school today
we are descendants of the gods
this land was always ours but we must
never relent
or nowhere and everywhere
you're from virginia can tell
you're special we are the future
[Music]
you you're not like the others
i'm coming
whoever you were before
that's over
what are we doing what is
the plan
what is your emergency
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very
uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i just started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend a partner
diliana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
[Applause]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
and makes you live through it until it
kills you
who's there
we can get out of this together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
[Music]
this
i'm gonna scale from one to ten how
bad's my rig
we drilled to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
got to get to the station how will you
even get there
we walk we just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
[Music]
what was that it's really tough
what is happening
there's something following us
underwater
[Music]
you